[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROBERT DESIMONE: MIT has some of
the world's greatest scientists
working on autism research.
And this new center
was established
to fund all new research
direction by those scientists.
We're going to apply
revolutionary new approaches
in biology to
understanding autism.
OMAR ABUDAYYEH: So gene
therapy is a type of treatment
that aims to correct
the problems that
occur in your DNA code.
My name is Omar Abudayyeh.
I'm an MD PhD student
at MIT and Harvard.
And Jonathan Gootenberg
is my work spouse.
One of the technologies
we've really been developing
is this new RNA editing
technology called REPAIR.
JONATHAN GOOTENBERG:
And REPAIR is
a system for taking
a specific letter
and changing it to
a different letter.
And so one really exciting
thing you could imagine
is, using our new
technology, we could
screen the hundreds or
thousands of mutations who've
seen patients with autism in
a dish or some sort of model
and actually try
to understand, what
are the most relevant mutations,
what pathways they act through.
And then when you get
that better understanding,
you start to have a map for
building better treatments.
GLORIA CHOI: So we
are specifically
looking at how the immune
activation during pregnancy
can lead to brain disorders
such as autism in offspring.
We would like to
understand how the gut
microbiome in the
mother's body actually can
modulate this entire process.
And we want to ask whether
we can take advantage
of this process to
either prevent or treat
the development of autism.
TOBIAS KAISER: Hey,
I'm Tobias Kaiser.
I work in Guoping Feng's lab.
And I'm also the
Tan Yang fellow.
My goals are similar to
those of most research.
You want to change
the world in some way.
So I'm doing two things mainly.
One is I understand
a gene that's highly
implicated in autism better.
And the second is that we
try to develop gene therapies
for those disorders.
So what I'm really
hoping is that, as we
focus on one disorder,
we can actually
expand these and generalize
some of these strategies,
also, to other disorders.
A.J. HASKINS: So this is a
really interesting puzzle
I'm A.J. Haskins.
I work in this building for
labs that recruit individuals
with autism.
So Dima and I have worked
on a couple of projects
together recruiting
individuals with autism
to do brain imaging studies.
DIMA AYYASH: It's really
hard to recruit and bring
in participants into
the lab for a study.
And so we often end
up with small samples.
And the sample is
not representative
of the whole spectrum.
What we are trying to
do is to aggregate data
from various labs at MIT,
but eventually, various
labs from all over
the world, ultimately,
to address a few of the
challenges of autism research.
ROBERT DESIMONE: When you
put the very best people
onto a problem and you
give them all the resources
they need to solve that problem,
I can't help but be hopeful.
I think we're entering a
new era of autism research.
And the end point is
going to be new therapies.
[MUSIC PLAYING]